hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
its Andrew here we're gonna do a spoiler
talk of The Punisher Marvel's Netflix
series if you haven't seen the show or
if you want to non-spoiler review we
just uploaded that video and Errol is
uploading a video on his channel this
week the movie source channel which is
gonna be all Easter eggs and references
that I'll take place throughout the 13th
episode season of The Punisher I'm sure
he might sprinkle in a couple here or
there I'll try in this video but if you
want to get all of them he showed me his
iPad as a huge breakdown of a lot of
things so keep a lookout for that video
in the meantime we'll just do a spoiler
talk right now
telling it's a relief to do a spoiler
talk because paint castle is the
punisher when you do a non-spoiler
review and you have to really watch out
make sure you that's it's harder for a
TV show you really got to elaborate I
can't though spoilers I guess I could
take a character my character here why
not start off with the man of the hour
Frank Castle I'm like not Mike Mike Mike
was great he was great Frank castles I
really really loved how this show
handled Frank in this in this series cuz
when it starts off it wraps up his story
he takes care of the rest of the people
that were involved in the shooting the
direct shooting of his family getting
hit by bullets and stuff he wipes them
all out in the beginning it's cool and
then the show goes into the actual mode
because that's more like a prologue when
the show starts off for it guess what
got the beer he's a construction worker
and you can see he's this guy who's
still haunted by the memory of his
family dying and I like that approach I
like the approach of he gets his revenge
he's not healed though cuz that is not
the true path to recovery and the big
themes of this show deal a lot with
grief but a show that has some pretty
sick gun action it also emphasizes how
haunting violence can actually be so
even though it's kind of weird because
there are times you're like sick cool
but this is real and disturbing at the
same time you know and I kind of like
how this show successfully pulled that
tone off there's this scene that they
talked about in daredevil season 2 the
major and when he's on trial for Frank
he's talking about
on a mission Frank just wiped out a
whole bunch of the enemy he just like
killed a bunch on his own and saved a
bunch of soldiers lives and then in this
show you get to see that scene you got
to see that
flashback scene the other thing I wish
about that scenes that they did it in
one take that would have been sweet well
yeah they kind of did that in daredevil
season two where he's just going through
all the prisoners yeah prison scene like
I don't know while but the way they shot
that was Oh incredible yes was still
amazing but when you compare it it's not
as good but still good to me that's a
defining moment of this whole show in
terms of how they handle the violence
because that has the entire thing I'm
talking about right there
it's so cool to watch what he's doing at
the same time this is a war scene so it
feels real it feels brutal and it feels
haunting especially when he takes that
rock and it's just smashing that off you
don't even see the face he smashing just
but you you can imagine didn't show it
cuz you can imagine what in your mind
and I think that's even scarier and when
he was just chomping down I kept on
thinking about Epson and Adrian but no I
agree with you I like we're haunted you
know they made this character in terms
of after he's finally accomplished his
goal in his mind thinking that he
finally finished off you know finishing
the vendetta against who would killed
his family I like how the show was
really smart though in terms of his
story like you know there's a lot of
different layers on covering his his
backstory in terms of you know what
really went down obviously we know the
major and there was the drug deals and
all that but obviously Frank you know
learning knowledge about that and then
we find out that actually his best
friend freaking betrayed him that was
something I really appreciate in the
show one of the themes is betrayal
I thought they you know dealt with it in
a very mature way and when you actually
like see the backstory showing the
nonlinear storytelling of the flashbacks
between Billy and and Frank yeah like it
actually makes it all the more painful
when you see him actually I mean
obviously it physically wasn't there but
he knew about it and didn't tell Frank
which is the ultimate betrayal you
because he's so clearly actors in the
writing sold that betrayal MO even
though it's like from the second he
shows up you're like all new all of us
they don't even remember Billy Russo's
jigsaw I did
jigsaws real name is Billy Russo but the
second he shows up you're like oh yeah
he's obviously a bad guy look how he's
coming across you're like this guy's
totally a bad guy yeah the scenes in the
flashback when they're overseas they
really sold that friendship I really
bought it to the point where I would
kind of doubt sometimes like Billy Russo
was actually a good guy another thing
that they have here it deals like what
betrayal is the themes of corruption -
you know how corrupt the US military can
sometimes be on certain aspects this
isn't a glorified one thing I was hoping
the show wouldn't do and they don't do
it make like a America yeah about the
show at all and it's not exactly screw
America either it's it's that gray that
this show deals with Frank has no
problem at all being a Marine I love
that moment waste time Michael a little
bit worried a little bit you know I had
two families that's a great moment
because I love his loyalty to not
feeling like I shouldn't have been a
Marine that was a big part of his
identity but also this whole thing deals
around this tape that shows a Madonna's
partner getting shot and Frank who pulls
the trigger and when you see that scene
and you see what Frank does and how he
handles it it gives you a deeper
understanding into the psychology of
Frank that's what I love about this show
it's really like a character study of
Frank Castle I think what I also loved
about Frank I mean Jon Bernthal gives an
amazing performance just in the action
sequences and the dramatic sequences the
sequences where you pick believe he's
being beaten to death yeah how does that
man survive with being beaten so much to
you like as that body takes so much
abuse it's all mental but I think what I
love so much about this character is how
methodical he is you know and like with
with Lois for instance like when he
started figuring it out this guy started
messing with his mind a little bit got
him to tell him how to cut the wire like
he's very intelligent and that's one
thing that gets me feeling that
relatable sensitive characters and gets
me in best of it gets me much more
investment in these characters is you
know when character is humor on the
humor side that's one way to get me and
also intelligence and he is a very
intelligent character in the way like I
said he methodically gets around
situations or through characters the way
he was working
caryn like the teamwork getting with the
wire with lures like that was a really
interesting woman saying I believe also
to that Lewis in this final moments in
that freezer was reading a poem from
Rudyard Kipling's the young British
soldier so that was pretty cool by the
way that character Lewis his name is
Lewis Wilson on a show that could be a
reference to Lewis Wilson the first
actor ever to play Batman in 1943 and
those four volumes 1 & 2 I told I'm that
thanks for telling me your of course of
course when you're talking about humor
law that comes out between him and Mike
Rowe yeah that friendship it was
interesting to me watching that develop
because there's a third or fourth
episode where I felt it dragged too too
long looking back on it it doesn't feel
that way now there's that one head of a
so yeah and the moment it felt like that
when when I'm being introduced to it
when I'm like okay I'm familiar with
Mike Rowe know you guys are gonna team
up it's pretty obvious you guys are
gonna team up so can we just get to you
guys teaming up instead of like Mike
Rose beaten naked into chair and all
this stuff but they're setting up all
the passcodes and everything of the camp
the security cameras recording at them
things that are gonna come in at the end
the retinal scans and how to input the
password all these things that they're
setting up for things that will
eventually pay off later do come full
circle and it does make sense of the
long run of why it took so long for
Frank to trust him after everything
that's been going on he knows that this
tape that Mike Rowe has is a big reason
for why his family was killed yada yada
yada he doesn't know if he could trust
the guy Frank already has trust issues
he doesn't work well with other people
but the way they build that relationship
like there's little touches in there of
humor that I really appreciated oh and
they're driving to that one mission and
Frank's eating a salad and then Mike
Rowe has a sandwich yeah it brings like
all pissed off because he has a sandwich
and the way their friendship builds what
are the more fascinating aspects of this
that when they initially got introduced
I was like I don't really know how I'm
gonna feel about seeing this in the show
but it became one of the more compelling
elements to me Mike Rowe has his family
that he keeps his eye on the whole time
and Frank sort of intervenes and gets
involved in the family's life and it's
this weird contrast that is so
compelling because Mike Rowe longs to
see his family and longs to be with his
family Frank doesn't have his family
anymore so he's kind of playing
vicarious father and vicarious husband
figure to Mike Rowe's family and Pam
when Mike Rowe's wife
I was like oh no not only that's doing
really quick fun little fact to go off
of that when they were kissing they were
both also played Jon Bernthal and the
actress who plays Sarah Lieberman I
believe it's Jamie Rae Newman if I'm
wrong sorry
they were also estranged husband and
wife on the TV show Eastwick hmm fun
fact there when I appreciated about that
relationship you said it all but just
I'm gonna echo more towards Mike Rowe
Stanley if they think his is the father
is dead they think Mike a David is gone
when Frank is kind of filling up that
void you know they're getting that said
I think that's why they work so well
together is because they're they're
building up some emotions that they both
have feel towards each other I mean one
obviously has lost his family you know
Frank in terms of he's lost his wife and
his kids obviously he's doing his friend
a favor
that means not friends yet with him but
partnering arms he's doing him a favor
but like you said where he's doing that
and he's being vicariously like that
father I also think too it's it's what's
keeping him seen cuz he doesn't have a
wife or kids a mourn like he wants that
feel even though he knows he's never
gonna go out with this woman he wants
that feeling of like having that family
touch again and and I appreciated that
they got that to one on the fan on David
Sarah's side as well where her and her
family think that David is gone and they
want someone to fill that void and
that's what Frank is and those moments
were so touching they were so emotional
and they were so that we're very bonding
and really cute I thought too that's the
thing about the show that I really love
is that virtually the daughter in
different yeah is that revenge doesn't
heal these wounds he's still recovering
from the loss of his wife and children
one of my favorite episodes was the
second-to-last episode Frank is tied
down to the chair and micros hideout and
William Rollins is like being the [ __ ]
it did this storytelling maneuver the
more Frank is dying look more he's
imagining being closer to his wife I
like the dream aesthetic day limbo yeah
limbo was like where's Professor
Dumbledore where one of the Transformers
what he's imagining his wife he feels
like he's getting closer to her and then
by
the end of it he's sort of making the
choice that he has to live he still has
to live that he can't just sacrifice
himself it was cool that micro showed up
because of that even though if he gets
his revenge by the end of this show I
love the ending of it I feel like the
ending the scene might be a little bit
like what the hell it's a weird place to
end but I think that's a great place for
the show to end like the sea for a
season one to end it's not going season
two set up but it is sort of leaving
room for it is leaving room for season
two of how he decides he gets his life
back he's PCAST the peat cast Aliona key
Castle EAS Leone and he's in the group
therapy session and he's saying I don't
have a war to fight and now I'm scared
you know and so he still has more
recovery to do but now he's getting the
proper treatment of course it's all
gonna go wrong in season two I like the
setup of Frank at least making the
choice to go I have to truly heal now
because I'm choosing to live this is a
story about a guy who it's like it's
very obvious this guy wants to die
throughout the entire show he only lives
to get revenge and by the time he has
his chance to complete his revenge just
at least bring Billy Rousseau down he
chooses to live and now he has to choose
to heal and that's such a beautiful part
of this journey something I wasn't
expecting at all going into the show was
watching a man who's grieving so heavily
decided he has to live and also with the
family dynamics it's a cool thing
because Frank is obviously tempted he
would love to be daddy to these kids and
he would love to dating Mike Rose why
everything you could tell he's super
into her and you can't blame the guy
she's a very attractive woman she's
totally making the moves on him even
though he's been kind of manipulative
and the way he kind of showed up and
does all these things you could tell
she's into him also it's such a good
character study because you could see
that she just misses her husband and
she's lonely and she'd just be using
Frank the way that all plays out even
when micro reunites with his family that
sex scene they have at porno scene he
finishes really quick yeah super quick
had computers for a year that I like I
was like tension-filled with them at
first and and has to do a lot with
forgiveness there's also some great plot
twists and turns I kept going on in this
show the way they did Billy Russo I
think it was smart that they gave him a
different background than his comic book
origin isn't the conference origin Billy
Bob Stern is Easter
yeah also in Punisher war zone of
Dominic West into the chainsaw yeah yeah
oh yeah no in that that's kind of how
his comic book origins are so I agree
with you I appreciated this different
taking I felt more personal now yeah at
the betrayal of him knowing that they
were gonna kill Frank's families I
thought it would have been even more
interesting if they would have said that
he actually went there and pulled the
trigger himself that would have been
like damn territory but obviously it
makes him way less flammable but not
that he was a redeemable character at
all in terms of it would it kind of
mirrored Frank in terms of that what he
had to do he where he has to live with
haunting does Billy have to live with
haunt in terms of what he did obviously
they didn't go that route but again I
just appreciated that side of the
relationship where he's not from his
comic book origins and it felt even more
personal rather than Oh punch you're
just going to kill the bad guy well the
cool thing about the Billy Russo
portrayal here is that he felt like a
human being he really felt like a human
being because even though this guy is
all about serving himself at no matter
what cost sacrificing family friends
whatever it's all about serving himself
he's willing to kill the girl he was
banging just so he can protect himself
he's the pretty boy he's a pretty boy
called pretty boy now there's constant
hints and moments of deeper emotion
there's that one scene with his mom
where just keeps her drugged up and he
hates the crap out her because he's so
hurt by how he was raising how he was
abandoned he's hurt this is great like
Tarantino liked standoff in the last
episode where Curtis gets shot by Billy
Russo in his apartment and Frank has a
sniper on him and there's like a lot of
dialogue going on between the three of
them it plays like a Tarantino likes
sequence even in that scene Billy is
hurt by the situation emotionally you
can tell Billy like yeah he's mad and he
wanted to kill them he was lying damn
Curtis yeah but he also he has feelings
too okay you know a lot of the seals
would choice an outcome and how PTSD
affects people one situation you get a
Curtis and you get a Frank type of PTSD
scenario and then you get a Billy Russo
type where it just kind of turns you on
to this dark side and you get the Lois
character aspect which I thought was
very fascinating because Lois the a lot
of the show when he's being set up I
kept going this is great PTSD
exploration of Strama ties war soldier
saving sounds like how the hell's is
tying in to anything
now how does this been thinking to hand
it off in a good way they paid it off in
a really well structured episode they
build up to Lois becoming this bomber
and he believes he's kind of like a
Frank Castle a Punisher type of hero for
the city as well that's another theme
this show deals with this the moral
boundaries yes yeah like an anarchy type
everything is corrupt politically you
know we're just the little guys were
being stepped on and I need to take a
stand so there were some interesting
messages going on in there too so the
character definitely had layers doom
leader he's hurt by the world and I was
taking it out on the world right the
world has rejected him especially as a
soldier who served this country it's
interesting take on the show where he
essentially becomes a villain at the
same time you understand why he's become
the way he is like you really built it
here like this guy was just an innocent
kid now because of all the cheese had to
go through and the constant rejection
he's had now he's become this bomber and
I like the way that all tied in because
even when he comes a bomber and there's
all that [ __ ] going down at the hotel I
was also thinking to myself is this
still essential to the entire plot like
it's interesting it's fascinating I like
the Franks becoming a hero but is this
really essential to everything that's
going on but then because of that scene
you get a lot of reveals Punisher
confronting McDonough Madani and Billy
Russo confronting each other all because
of this bombing sequence that all led to
this that was all very powerful stuff
also the bomber causes Frank to be
revealed to the public that he's still
alive and that was such a great touch to
make him the man on the hunt again and
he still any just embraces being the
Punisher I also like how this show
that's seen in different scenarios where
they showed yeah not only different time
lapses but they showed it from a
perspective I've seen where you showed
like a character even if the character
was lying they showed you the lying
version yeah oh yeah actually flying and
that's what that kid the poet the
politician just saving his ass was
saying so but I appreciated that like
instead of just the character saying oh
yeah Punisher helped me helped him and
he shot him they actually showed it to
like almost confuse us so I actually
appreciated that and you said it was
really well structured and I thought
that character was very interesting too
especially how they ended it because I
was thinking like most of the way
through like where is this exactly going
but it was done it interesting and it
paid off for me and
when he served his purpose for the plot
for all the reveals to come out yeah he
kills himself so they didn't drag his
story out either like his once they
build it up in a good way lady and all
the constant rejection him being in a
hole yeah and all that stuff like you
could feel like dude this fool is about
to snap and I think that's also
something I really appreciate about this
show the dramatic tension and all the
the suspense it built because like these
are just normal care these aren't
supervillains with superpowers whenever
Billy Russo's got a knife or whenever
Luis is on like I feel like these
characters could snap at any moment and
that's really terrifying at me so when
you can terrify me without superpowers I
thought that was really powerful job on
those actress parts and a Madani
storyline was something that I just
couldn't get on board with the first few
episodes I feel like they filled screen
time with her because they needed to
because they have 13 episodes I could
have used less of her in the first half
and then use more of her in the second
half like a lot of that could have been
trimmed out for me this is the slow
build of something that I just wasn't
really appreciating every time a
character showed up to talk to her they
all gave her some psychological study
about her and then they go full-out with
her mom more psychologically is the way
she is
I don't care just move it along would
you her story starts getting more
interesting when she gets in the car
chase with Frank when she gets in that
car chase with Frank and you see like
okay this is a little bit more of a
badass character right now she knows
Frank is alive it has to keep it a
secret I could have done with the first
three episode just like a scene or two
of Herman I don't need like a lot of the
episode dedicated to her her story wraps
up nicely too I like how her story deals
with forgiveness was especially when she
learns that Frank is the one who killed
her partner she's the one who pulled the
trigger and she has to his phone but she
has to also see past that she has to
eventually learn to see Frank is
actually a good guy and he deserves it
deserves a second chance of life after
all the sacrifices he's made that was a
really nice touch to it I thought she
got killed at the end yeah me too when
she got popped in the head yeah I mean
but everyone's I mean you it see it's I
mean I thought Billy I know that we're
gonna turn to jigsaw at that point but
before that all reveals like how can you
survive these these situations but hey
and when Billy turns into jigsaw I was
like it really and II be freakin ruin
for me man and I didn't look at that
that was a sick way the goodness aw that
was I like the way they become jigsaw
here because they made it such a
personal touch yeah cuz they're really
setting it up in the show they keep
talking about how pretty Billy Russo is
it he's got the pretty face oh yeah he's
very pretty keep pointing that out these
keep setting up they're gonna [ __ ] his
face up by the NRA or they're gonna say
it in a funny maniacal way yeah and
people say nice face pretty boy now he's
gonna pop someone in the head when they
say it was a great choice not to kill a
mom cuz a lot of the people Frank just
offs right away and so I thought like
okay Frank's gonna kill him off then I
was thinking well that's kind of a
bummer that we didn't get a chance to
see Billy Russo embody the jigsaw role
and his reasoning for not killing him
off was pure Punisher style too he
punishes him he like stems that has
brutal scraping his face against the
last Terry office yeah that was crunchy
that was very crunchy it's called The
Punisher you got more than just him
killing people you got to have some
scenes where he's punishing some
[ __ ] like he is getting
long-term punishment right then and
there
yeah yeah cuz Billy lives to keep
himself pretty you know yeah Curtis I
thought was a great character too he was
that cool character you know he's got
the peg leg and everything he's that
character who's really working on
healing but one thing that showed us so
well the inner turmoil in the inner
conflicts is even though he's the one
who's constantly encouraging these
soldiers to open up and heal and
whoop-ass you can see that he hasn't
fully done so either and that he has a
lot more work to do as well and even
touching on themes like that like gun
control this show did something that I
did not see coming the discussions on
gun control this show does not take
sides it actually talks about why people
need guns and it talks about why people
shouldn't have guns it really
capitalizes on both I can really see why
this show did not have an event at my cc
gun talk is so big in such a crucial
element to this show in the effect of
violence as well I wasn't expecting that
to be such a such a strong topic but I
appreciated the show doesn't make you go
guns are bad or guns are good they just
kind of like both black and white at the
end a gray area in between yeah
absolutely and with Curtis I'm excited
to see what they'll do with him for
season 2 because I know he's one of
Punishers main guys he's one of the main
Pete
that should be part of like Punishers
team what's neat about him is he's the
one who probably has the good guy act up
the best out of all of them but even but
if Frank needs his help he'll be out in
the field helping out you know yeah he's
also a good one to have a run if you're
beat yeah yeah well these guys the their
PTSD and then seeing that he's the
common guy in the group like you said
really found myself surprisingly very
invested in their relationship with each
other like I really appreciated their
interactions I thought they had very
good chemistry together whenever he was
on I like Frank the personal touch to of
when you know Curtis is tied up and
beaten up as the bomb on him how Frank
reveals that Frank feels responsible for
why Curtis has the life that was a great
scene yeah the dramatic and emotional
human depth a feeling that Moe in that
moment is how I feel so guilty situation
right now you're very understand then
just getting to microts you again I
really appreciated where they started
his story and if you know the comics
obviously you know what's gonna happen
with this character but if you're just
coming into the show not knowing too
much the way he's like surveilling Frank
and how they start with him like is he
the deal with this guy and then when you
see like he was given the the the
surveillance footage and I believe it
was gunner yeah right Gunners the one
who sent it to him by opening it [ __ ]
screws up his life yeah so and I
appreciate with where they took his
story and where it paid off because I
mean this man has had to sacrifice
everything for a whole year be on the
run and make his family think that they
were dead so I thought I appreciated
what this actor did with seeing what
goes on inside of a man who is watching
his family feels like he's right there
but is actually dead and feels that way
too because that could mentally get to a
person like being alive and being so
close to your family but having them
believe you're dead and you can't do
anything about it because you could
jeopardize them and I thought they
handled it in a very mature way and I
appreciated those moments they just got
me that much more invested in the
character and what he has to go through
their relationship is kind of the center
of this show every other one of the
themes derives from these two characters
Punisher and micro and when they start
off they kind of just need each other
they're kind of using each other they
form a very strong connective bond a
very strong tissue that scene when micro
goes to save Punishers
he's like my friends dying and stuff you
can see I believe that I'm like Michael
really cares about this actually they've
grown together micro got his family back
because of Frank micro gives a huge [ __ ]
about about Frank by the end of it Frank
doesn't get all mushy mushy with him but
you can see Frank really cares about
micro - also in terms of making micro an
essential element for these missions I
love the way that they built that up
because there was a time where it just
seems like this micro need to be out in
the field this micro need to be there
there's that one episode specifically
when they go to see gunner it's like how
are they gonna get out of the situation
you're in the woods and these these
micro uses the drone is open and not on
- cool micros essential that was
brilliant and the brutality when he gets
shot in the arm and that take out the
whole team like it is so violently show
the violence sequences are great I've
got the John wick like kind of vibe when
I was watching these other sequences so
I think my favourite action sequence
would have to be the one where they've
heard the the Special Ops people first
invade micros hideout and then Frank's
like I'm gonna wait for them you know
that was cool it's like pure punisher
style like yeah let them come I'm just
gonna wait here I'm gonna kill all of
them why do I have to go up running away
oh man this show really knows it's
caring and I also appreciate the moment
when Billy was talking to one of the
soldiers and right after he died like
Frank call him back and when he heard
nothing's like Frank it makes them more
intelligent these characters and I
appreciate little moments like that he
knows when no one's talking to him and
breathe and just so I can hear his
breath he's like yeah I know that's
Frank's I love it when characters can go
into like mentally go into different
places when they're being beaten and
they can laugh about it like it just it
makes the characters more interesting
because they're taking some brutal
punishment like watching the blood
squirt on him you could tell why this
guy whine like when Frank freaking
punched his eye out that way I remember
when we were watching
Oh like that was because I mean you can
understand why Frank would do that but
seeing that that actor appreciated his
facial expressions and emotions I felt
like this is for my eye like I look in
he gets to an explosive emotional point
it's kind of just cooling calm
yeah exactly and he gets to a point
where he's just he's just lost it that's
seen though when Billy decides to use
the pliers to cut off Frank's uh yeah
things hang tough that was really well
done because they were setting up that
buildings probably gonna kill him that's
an interesting scene to analyze because
it makes me wonder was Billy giving
Frank an opportunity to live or giving
Frank an opportunity to get his revenge
or was Billy just using Frank for that
moment because because he knows that
Rollins would it will hate to get killed
by Frank to answer your question I
really again just from watching another
one time I think that he had realized
from everything from the way that Rawls
was interacting with him like this fool
is gonna give me I could give me up or
as probable already giving me up at any
point the way he's talking like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] at all about me even
though he's not a man of honor he did
make a promise as a brother that he
would he'd be the one to kill him so was
those two factors going into that and
again when you treat over-the-top like
like a piece of [ __ ] to a character
they're good in moments like that the
turn makes sense like it's actually you
buy this it was emotionally motivated
that entire think it was not just plot
heavy-handed it was emotionally
motivated and that's what made it so
powerful Frank refreshing in his eyeball
Oh gave me some Michael Myers trim I
felt like I was watching Oh Mike even
got the bad I to like good and then
watching Billy like just maniacally
stare at it like he's enjoying yeah yeah
what I enjoyed about that scene was also
Frank again when I talked out earlier
about him being very methodical he just
knows what he that's his brother that's
like his best friend he knows like what
pushes Billy's buttons and like he's
kind of manipulating him psychologically
where he's just like telling him things
you know make him like again promise to
kill him only and like he's just putting
all these things in his head that again
where you get to the emotional payoff
and that moment that's heard it's like
it wasn't just an emotional path like
Frank put in his head like what needed
to be heard on top of the bad guy giving
him that emotional moment where that's
earned so I just that's where I
appreciated like Jon Bernthal Frank
castles he's not just gonna punish and
kill you like he's methodical he's
intelligent like I think yet
psychologically in your head like where
he gets with Lewis and or in this case
and
so depends on who he's killing that's
just a guy with a gun show him so
there's kill him
yeah but then if it's like a personal
death he makes it a personal death
that's where this show is able to draw a
fine line between murderer vigilante
killer her because he refuses punishing
everyone left and right like actually
punishing them like oh he only punishes
quite a few in this old chef this was
great this is this is a really well
human told show that really pays honored
of veterans in a strange way makes you
know veterans cool at the same time you
could really understand their trauma I
mean I can't fully grasp their trauma
but it gives you a deep insight into it
and I appreciate that Marvel made his
show it took time out to tell such a
human tail it was more impactful than I
expected to be emotionally I was just
showing up to watch a cool show about a
guy killing a bunch of people I was not
expecting that yeah it was it was a nice
surprise it's a really human story I
don't know if he made it to the end of
this video it's a long ass video
hopefully you say it's at the end you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell Andrew is on the
movie source channel on YouTube keep a
look out for his Easter eggs and
references video all on the punisher
come a picture on rejected a I have a
lot of fun perks over there take care of
people